the war has begun and one question
remains
on July 6 two years under house arrest
you haven't had any contact with Hank or
hope have you hmm real heroes
and man the wash teen another not actual
size awesome
if only cap could see you now that man
and the wasp get tickets now everything
you know everything you've experienced
has all led to this is that my desk yeah
why do I have such a small desk well cuz
you do you want that one lurch isn't
that your snooze you lose I was under
house arrest
yeah guys Pope come on we got to focus
on July 6
this is garbage I got it at a rummage
sale ant-man and the wasp get tickets
tomorrow so how long have you been
Antonin again no uh I just sort of
happened it's like bad guys like you
[Music]
I seem to mess it up almost every time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch for
back
like a person
[Music]
dr. pan I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when he's crazy could be ghosts
well like walks through walls and stuff
so Leo tech now supposed to take over
the world or whatever
who to believe that in your hour of need
you would turn the house at me because
we robbed you do you remember that's us
feeling chest regret this both of you
and man and the wasp teaming up follow
my lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
[Music]
we're gonna die
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
I was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet you 65 feet 65 if you to
our finish comparing sizes 65
[Music]
you